how much longer you gonna be don't rush
this I don't even get why you still come
here I thought you had Netflix I do but
this there's something about video
stores Netflix just doesn't have and I'm
sure you're about to tell us what that
is the impulse meant think about it sure
you can browse the online selection at
Netflix or Amazon but it's not the same
as a movie catching your eye in the eye
oh maybe it's the early work of an actor
you like maybe it's the Forgotten film
of a great director or something even
less tangible like box art box art you
and me should appreciate that how do you
figure you told me yourself but there
were two movies that opened up your mind
to the fact that animation could be more
than just Saturday morning cartoons and
Disney movies heavy metal and ghost in
the shell and what did those two have in
common
oh geez don't do this was it naked lady
on the box
naked lady on the box what I was 16
the point is impulse rentals aren't
always general but they're special and
the experience needs to be preserved
there's no impulse online you see a star
rating read viewer reviews it sits in
your queue giving you time to put it off
or second-guess it the magic is gone
finished
singing in the rain I thought you only I
do new release with enhanced image and
retrospective with gene Kelly's nephew
whatever man come on
what the hell crap who the hell watches
that junk Dave don't engage people who
consistently put it on the best films of
all time lists that's who
oh yeah well whatever you know that
stuff makes you gay wrong musical you're
thinking sound of music sing listen
douche
let's just go I really want Batman and
Robin okay now you can Kenan oh what the
Reds will help you even have the
retrospective on it